do you see him do you think a depressed
person could make this
no no i'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and i'm
always tired
also i can't sleep i'm overeating none
of my old hobbies interest me
i have done nothing wrong ever
in my life i know this
and i love you oh it's a white flag and
you may as well start waving it right
now
i will be waving is your decapitated
head on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good lord this is my friend madison
she's amazing and she drove me here
it's beautiful i've looked at this for
five hours now
hi i just wanted you to know we're about
to be arrested
ah look who hasn't had gay thoughts
what i love garbage jogging is the worst
chris
i mean i know it keeps you healthy but
god at what cost stay back
[ __ ] someone will die of fun
because we're smart not to worry
i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want
oh i have a medical condition all right
it's called caring too much
and it's incurable what that is totally
crazy i am super chill all the time
i'm dead oh lord is he eating soup
on a bench alone i have total faith in
you
there's like a 30 chance they'll both
die
if i keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times
i will avoid falling into a bottomless
pit of despair
it's about the cones thank you officer
let's just go home
yeah let's go ahead and just go home no
just go home no
no everything hurts and i'm dying
[Applause]
[Applause]
stop pooping
i know more than you all right
somebody follow me i'm distraught the
calzones
betrayed me hey no no
no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
this place is outstanding oh so just
because i can't go out with them someone
else can
oh boy wow okay
thank you alcohol
[Applause]
i am 100 certain that i am zero percent
sure of what i'm going to do
i'm never gonna be a cop i'm gonna have
to be a robber i'm
not crying okay i'm allergic to jerks
my anxiety has kept me up for over 50
hours
boom sadness that's the one
oh
leslie are you okay
[Music]
if i was sick could i do this
what are you doing cartwheels
am i not doing them no treat yo self
treat yourself 2 2011. from now on we'll
be using code names you can address me
as eagle one anne codename been there
done that
april is currently doing that donna is
it happened once in a dream chris code
name if i had to pick a dude
ben is eagle two oh thank god
look even ben's dancing no thinking
just stupid never half ass two things
whole ass one thing how are you i'm
dying
i guess my thoughts on abortion are you
know let's just all have a good time
oh my god i'm gonna die someday
i want to throw up and kill myself get
these balloons out of here
buttery's my favorite food i'd work all
night if it meant nothing got done
mommy please my money
she's the worst person i've ever met i
want to travel the world with her
i'm gonna go powder my nose amongst
other things
if you know what i mean
is she gonna powder her vagina i need to
go lie down for 45 minutes
no an hour a full
hour
[Music]
i'm waiting on my arm andy
[Music]
i'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing
and i'm putting him down
[Music]
i'm feeding your eagle he's starving
i think we can agree that all wine
tastes the same
and if you spend more than five dollars
on wine you are
very stupid no tragically we are both
heterosexual
do you see the problem here yes but i
don't want to
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have i like
people places
and things
i know this is a dire situation but i
swear to god this is like a crazy sex
fantasy for me
i regret nothing the end i like saying
no
it lowers their enthusiasm and i'll have
the number eight
that's a party platter it serves 12
people i know what i'm about son
i have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
i ate a brownie once at a party in
college
it was intense it's kind of
indescribable actually i
felt like i was floating turns out there
wasn't any pot in the brownie it was
just an insanely good brownie
i feel great i ran 5k this morning
really
no i threw up in the shower april
you're like an angel with no wings so
like a person
there are no consequences to my actions
anymore no matter what i do literally
nothing bad can happen to me i'm like a
white male u.s senator
oh god did i peak when i was 18. leslie
i typed your symptoms into the thing up
here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems every time
you look up at the moon
i too will be looking at a moon not the
same moon obviously that's impossible
we're all just molecules floating around
in random patterns
devoid of meaning
thank you
i really needed this
[Music]
how do i get to the stage
[Music]
no
no i didn't win but at least i didn't
make any new friendships
you know my code hose before bros
uterus is before deuteros got it ovaries
before broveries
i'm not afraid of cops red carpet insole
everywhere i go i'm walking on red
carpet
and they would never cancel game of
thrones it's a crossover hit
it's not just for fantasy enthusiasts
they're telling human stories in a
fantasy world
tommy t you just missed the craziest of
crazies
clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here
crashing on your couch for a week cause
technically i'm homeless
you